thank you
good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight happy Friday it has been
a long week in the news business all
sorts of things you thought could never
happen did in fact happen and then vice
versa a whole lot of predictions failed
to materialize the big theme of the week
as usual was lying there was an
extraordinary amount of lying at this
point the people in charge seem like
they tell the truth only by accident
occasionally somebody in power will say
something true and is swiftly punished
for it can't have that
it's infuriating to watch but it's also
if you look at it right very amusing
these are not sophisticated deceptions
this is not Dwight Eisenhower's
stealthily planning D-Day this is your
five-year-old ambling in with frosting
on his face to tell you he never touched
the birthday cake should that make you
mad of course it should make you mad but
if you're human you will also laugh at
it cake what cake it's hilarious the kid
has no idea how ridiculous he is
so with that spirit in mind we're going
to devote the next hour to a special
presentation on lying in American
politics so we're going to do our best
to stay amused because that's much
better than being angry
and we're going to start with what could
be the funniest lie of the Year Vladimir
Putin blew up Russia's natural gas
pipeline to Europe
now why would Putin do something like
that well they told us because he's evil
Putin is so evil that he murdered his
own country's economy purely for the
dark thrill of doing it that's evil it
takes a bad man to declare war against
himself next Putin will be invading
Moscow
so that was their story the story that
bite Administration told us and then
every single news organization in the
country with no exceptions at all backed
up the LIE of course Putin did it they
lectured us don't ask questions or
you're a Russian agent
there was for a moment a perfectly
united front of falsehood on the
question of what happened to Nordstrom
but it wasn't enough the story was too
absurd to stand even by the standards of
2023. anyone who thought about it for
even a moment realized that of course
Vladimir Putin didn't blow up his own
pipeline why would he do that
the Biden Administration blew up
Vladimir Putin's pipeline of course Joe
Biden himself had promised on camera
that he would do it and then Biden
officials publicly celebrated after it
happened so every rational person knew
the truth
so after a few months the people who lie
for a living decided to make up a news
story unfortunately this one was even
dumber and less believable
okay they can see that Putin didn't do
it that was wrong we'll admit it was not
Putin who blew up the pipeline
it was the ukrainians but not the
ukrainians you're familiar with the ones
who are getting billions of American tax
dollars every month no no not our
Ukrainian friends they would never do
that
it was ukrainians we've never met it was
Rogue ukrainians acting against Russia
but with no connection to the bid
Administration whatsoever these are good
people fighting for a noble cause but
doing it entirely on their own without
our Assistance or knowledge
that's what the New York Times told us
actually happened
and then everybody swallowed it watch
CNN in a separate but parallel story
we've been learning more Kates about the
Nordstrom attack you remember the
Nordstrom pipeline back in September uh
saw an explosion a sabotage effort it is
the subject of an ongoing investigation
by German authorities according to your
Times report they say that they believe
that according to sources it may have
been perpetrated by a group aligned with
the aims of Kiev but not actually backed
by Kiev not run by Kiev an independent
group acting on its behalf and in its
name
totally independent now imagine if you
found yourself repeating something that
ridiculous on television here you have
an explosion
a three-part explosion that was part of
a deep sea operation in the Baltic Sea
300 feet under water that happened at
exactly the moment that NATO war games
were going on in the area so you would
think that there was probably some
involvement from a military somewhere
but no says the lady on the TV repeating
the New York Times it was a shadowy
unnamed group of totally independent
ukrainians who happen to live in a
country that the Biden Administration
runs and whose pensions are being paid
for by you
right totally independent
does anyone really believe that there's
a single human being including the hair
hats repeating it actually believe that
no
and that's the thing about so many of
these lies you don't believe them but
you're not special nobody believes them
even the people repeating them
and nowhere is that more true than on
the question of the climate emergency
here's the climate emergency
that's what climate change is about it
is literally not figuratively a clear
and present danger the latest climate
report nothing less than quote code red
for Humanity let me say it again code
read for Humanity okay so you can buy
that or not and by the way a lot of good
people some smart people people of good
faith do believe that and that's okay
but do the people telling you that
believe it does Joe Biden actually think
that climate change is code red for
Humanity
well don't listen to what he says watch
what he does this week Biden spoke to
Canada's prime minister Justin Trudeau
about how terrifying this climate
emergency is but he didn't talk to
Trudeau on Zoom no
instead he flew on a private airplane to
the capital of Canada
Ottawa where he and Justin Trudeau drove
around the city in a 20 vehicle Convoy
complete with ambulances and armored
vehicles now if you were concerned about
climate change being driven by humans in
the burning of fossil fuels which
produce carbon dioxide you probably
wouldn't behave like that you probably
get on the phone and talk about climate
change but they didn't
and none of the global warming experts
who are telling you that your suburban
is a sin said a word about it
in fact they were busy lecturing about
the rest your wood stove your gas stove
you remember in January the gas stove
ban was a conspiracy theory anyone who's
worried about the government cracking
down on their kitchen was a nut case a
Ruby Ridge level wacko
the Republic reported back then and
we're quoting people are getting real
heated over a gas stove band that isn't
happening note and appreciate the pun
so that's always the first move you're
imagining it crazy person
then we move forward a couple of months
and the conspiracy theory is actually
well it's it's true and if you disagree
with it you're a wacko this is from a
Politico a political blog in Arlington
Virginia yesterday quote New York near's
deal to ban gas stoves in new homes
[Laughter]
so they say something if you take it
seriously it's your fault
because it's not true and then they tell
you that in fact it is true and if you
don't agree with it
you're a criminal you see this a lot
you're told something you're required to
believe something that's clearly false
and if you don't go along with it you're
banned from social media and harassed
and maybe you can't use Airbnb and maybe
if you keep talking JP Morgan cancels
your bank account
and then once you submit they admit
actually yeah you're right
now you've seen this in on a lot of
different topics but you never saw it
more clearly at a more sustained Pace
than over the three years of covid
remember they told you of course you
remember because they told you every day
this was a pandemic of the unvaccinated
it is as we've said a pandemic and an
outbreak of the unvaccinated this is
becoming a pandemic of the unvaccinated
as Dr wolenski said on an earlier an
earlier briefing today this is really
becoming a pandemic of the unvaccinated
still a long way to go
the fact is this has been a pandemic of
the unvaccinated
yeah so we're going to use this Global
pandemic which was a legitimate Health
threat
to push our political goals into vilify
and isolate and punish with law
enforcement people who didn't vote for
us if you're trying to convince people
to fear doctors and never go to the
doctor again
this is exactly what you would do and of
course that's the effect for millions of
people faith in our medical system has
evaporated because of their lying and of
course another line because the vaccines
started getting coveted at a higher rate
than people who exercised and ate well
and maybe developed natural immunity so
in the face of that undeniable science
they had to change their talking points
but for some reason nobody told Senator
Tina Smith of Minnesota to update her
talking point so here she was on Tuesday
of this week assuring everyone in the
words of the advertisements this
medicine is safe and effective thank you
Mr Menzel for being with us today
so I want to start by just saying that
the covid-19 vaccine is safe and
effective
[Laughter]
seen Creed you just repeat it every week
you don't think about what it means you
just repeat the slogans it's literally a
liturgy
safe and effective really a shot that
gives hard people young people heart
inflammation without protecting them
from Cova that's safe and effective
all this does all this level of lying
does is make people cynical not simply
about the people in charge you have
every reason to be cynical about them
but about words themselves is there a
connection between a word and a physical
observable reality or I'm not sure
anymore
Korean Jean-Pierre at the White House
has never even thought about that or
much
here she is confronted with the evidence
the Biden family took a seven-figure
payout from China watch carefully maybe
for the first time in your life to how
she responds
Versailles says they've got bank records
showing a Chinese Energy company paying
three Biden family members through a
third party what were they paid for
look I'm just not going to respond to
that from here look we have heard from
House Republicans for years in years and
years
how how the inaccuracies and lies when
it comes to this issue
and I don't even where to begin to even
answer that question because again it's
been lies and lies and inaccuracy for
the past couple years and I'm just not
going to get into it from here
yeah just not getting it here's some
bank records here are some numbers on
paper that no one disputes are real what
do you say to this Republicans lies
years uh in other words you're sopping
wet the water seems to be coming from
the sky is it raining lies lost hahaha
of course that's their response they
always accuse you of exactly what they
themselves are doing remember when they
told you that John Federman was totally
qualified to be a senator and he had no
debilitating mental issues whatsoever in
fact he's way sharper than you are shut
up Dumbo
whatever happened to John fetterman by
the way
where is he supposed to be serving in
the U.S Senate can someone take a
picture of him holding up today's paper
so we can be certain
but crane John Pierre doesn't care
Republicans lies it's been years
and of course she has to say that
because she does not want to get into
the details about what her own boss the
president of the United States is saying
who really seems and will concede in a
very amusing way utterly disconnected
from reality so he began his campaign
you probably remember right around 2019
from telling us how he liberated Nelson
Mandela from Robert Island from prison
in South Africa and it's just gotten
more florid from there and we are
absolutely determined to be amused by
Joe Biden so here he is telling you that
during Selma he was actually at the
Forefront of civil rights he may have
been on the Edmund Pettis Bridge watch
this I was a student up north in the
Civil Rights Movement I remember feeling
how guilty I was
I wouldn't hear you
how could we all be up there
and you going through what you're
looking at those I can still picture you
still picture Troopers of the batons and
Wands and whips
can you even imagine what Joe Biden's
actual racial attitudes were in 1963 in
Delaware is the same Joe binder told us
he was in the car with his dad 60 years
ago and talked saw two men in downtown
Wilmington kissing each other and his
father said Joe you've got to support
gay marriage
laughs
nothing almost metaphysical going on
here you have people who believe if they
say something it will become true their
words will create reality itself
wow that's the same standard by the way
that the by-deministration seems to be
applying to what's happening to the
former president
and to children and gender ideology they
want you to believe that eight-year-old
boys can become women overnight
just by wishing for it that's why kamela
Harris just sent a letter pray ing a man
dressed as a woman that's why she goes
around yapping about her pronouns we
can't resist this clip it's too great I
am Kamala Harris my pronouns are she and
her I am a woman sitting at the table
wearing a blue suit
so we're not going to say anything
snarky about that that's just so great
and if there's one piece of video
evidence that we can save and the Time
Capsule inside all of our hearts to
represent what it was like to live in
this country in 2023 it's that right
there Kamala Harris
she her my pronouns and I'm wearing a
pantsuit yes you are
so one of the great lies going on right
now is that the former president United
States who was also once again the front
runner for the Republican nomination
Donald Trump has committed some kind of
crime
in the state of New York for which at
some point he's going to be indicted now
we could have had a lot of people on to
talk about this Trump Defenders people
who voted for Trump we thought it would
be more credible and probably a lot more
interesting to have someone who did not
vote for Trump who does not agree with
Trump but who's pretty serious about the
law and has spent his life in it